[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] إن
إسقاط كرة تايم سكوير هو السمة المميزة لليلة رأس
السنة الجديدة.
قبل دقيقة واحدة من الأول من يناير،
تبدأ الكرة المتلألئة في الهبوط، إنها
هنا فقط في مدينة نيويورك حيث ترى
مليون شخص يتجمعون لمشاهدة
كرة مضاءة.  النزول على عمود العلم، وبينما
نقوم بالعد التنازلي، نتعانق ونقبل
ونحتفل، لقد حدث إسقاط الكرة
سنويًا منذ عام 1907، وقد توقف لمدة
عامين خلال الحرب العالمية الثانية، لكن الحشود
ما زالت تتدفق إلى تايم سكوير حتى عام 1995،
وتم إدارة إسقاط الكرة بواسطة
الشركة العائلية لنجمها المبدع جاكوب الأول
منذ ذلك الحين، كان هناك العديد من
التعديلات على الكرة الشهيرة بما في ذلك أحجار
الراين والكريستال والإضاءة القوية
في عام 2020، سقطت الكرة في
الشوارع الفارغة حيث تم استضافة الحدث
افتراضيًا بسبب تدابير كوفيد-19
التي نزلت فوق
حشد محدود يبلغ 15000 شخص في عام 2021 مع احتفالات واسعة النطاق مما
يؤدي إلى عودة مظفرة
إلى الحلبة في
عام 2023، سواء كان لهذه الطقوس الدائمة
جمهور قليل أو كثير، فهي
تمثل دائمًا نهاية القديم وبداية
الجديد.